and the mutation of all these viruses I
don't know I think all the experiments
work out because this is just like
something we're crying right it sounds
like gain a function to me
I don't know it's a little bit different
I think it's different it's like there's
it's definitely not gonna when the
liberal establishment yells at all of
the awful unvaccinated skeptical
conspiracy theorist people for not
trusting the public authorities the only
answer can be yes we don't trust the
public authorities and that's not our
fault if the public authorities were not
constantly lying to us and then bragging
about lying to us and then lying to us
some more after they got caught
red-handed I would be more inclined to
trust them but it's been at least three
years now that they've been doing this
they keep getting caught red-handed and
so don't accuse me of wearing a tinfoil
hat when I simply repeat their words
back to them they are liars